good afternoon everybody
i am absolutely delighted uh that you
are here with us today for this very
very special event and i'm particularly
excited to
welcome my friend the governor to toro
this is not his first visit to our
campus but it's the first visit since
we've been renovating the building this
is the first event we've had in this new
area and we're very proud to be able to
show it off atturo has been in the
forefront of our state's fight against
covid the pandemic has been difficult
for all of us but toro students and
faculty have stepped up to keep our
fellow citizens safe
toro students were the first to test the
homeless for culvert at cashman field
our faculty and students under the
direction of our medical school dean dr
wolfgang produced more than 20 000 pcr
test kits for the state when we didn't
have any
thanks to michael tang who's here with
us
toro provided almost 200 000 mass to
local hospitals doctors nursing homes
hospices and to the metropolitan police
department our students with the help of
our dean of students who is also here
today phil tompkins who also chairs our
coven task force started a program named
med ready to provide free tutoring for
school children that were having trouble
transitioning to virtual and helping
older americans who could not leave
their house with their shopping needs
and errands uh dr rebecca edgeworth who
i know is also here in the back and our
physician assistant students we're out
in the community they're out in the
community every week doing vaccine pods
and providing health care to homeless
and underserved southern nevadans to
date we have administered over 20 000
vaccines and still counting
governor where are you there you are um
before i turn the program over to you i
want you to know that the faculty staff
and students at toro are great fans of
the first lady
she is yes i know she is an elegant
charming dedicated hard-working first
lady we are very lucky and we are very
proud that she represents us
and now governor sislek i want to
formally welcome you to touro university
which is the largest medical school and
po a pa program in the state and has a
mandatory vaccine policy we thank you
for your leadership and support and
welcome you most wholeheartedly to toro
thank you shelley i really really
appreciate that especially the shout out
from my wife who was uh
my uh rock and my support and
i can't thank her enough we've had an
issue with asian hate lately and she has
stood tall for the asian american
community and opposed asian hate and i
want to say a little bit about toro
before i get into my
written remarks here
toro was at the forefront at the
beginning of the pandemic and what
shelley said and she didn't take enough
credit for it at the very beginning we
did not have test kits they had to
assemble
test kits to put together to give people
tests that means getting the swabs and
the agent the tubes and all that stuff
in different places
and perform putting assembling them and
then performing the tests
and mr tank we didn't have face masks i
mean
we were flying them in from you know
from china and uh the middle east
wherever we could get them from macau
sent us some
uh we used every connection we possibly
had and the face masks were more
important than
really dollars i mean because you
couldn't buy face masks it was so
important and
toro has been on the lead in terms of
this and i see the students regularly uh
my staff megan and randy are both here
uh
i see the toro students out at the
events where we're doing the testing and
we're doing the vaccines and i can tell
you it's a very calming influence
particularly for our people that are a
little anxious going in for the test or
a little hesitant going in for the test
and you provide a calming influence and
i don't know if that's something that
they teach you here
but it's noticeable when that happens
and we sincerely thank you for that
because you've made
uh
our lives better because you were able
to administer the test but more so than
that i can tell you
the vaccines that you're giving out and
that you have given out have saved lives
that we can't quantify the number of
lives that it is that can't point to a
particular individual whose life you've
saved but you have absolutely saved
lives because of the injections that
you've given
and on behalf of over 3 million people i
call the great state of nevada home i
want to tell you thank you for that
because it's remarkable the work that
you do so we appreciate you so now i'm
going to go to my prepared remarks
because i feel like you can just skip
them at this point yeah thank you
yeah i'm going to get through you're
right uh
i did i talked about most of this stuff
you know
uh toro has been i'm gonna go to the
bottom has been helping fight this
pandemic we're grateful for their work
and now getting on to the winners which
is what we're all here for sorry about
that
[Applause]
okay we're gonna have some smiles when
we start announcing the winners this
week there are ten
five thousand dollar college savings
plan winners and the college savings
plans which were
really the brainchild of zach conan our
treasurer and my chief of staff michelle
white are just incredible to see these
young folks
get a scholarship get a savings account
as you call it for education and it's
going to go a long long way for them
because
the group that's 12 to 17 we couldn't
put them in the big drawing so this is
very important so this week there are 10
5 000 winners college savings plans
that's money for college anywhere in the
united states anywhere they want to go
hopefully you'll stay in nevada but you
know you don't have to uh so let me
start from northern nevada i'm going to
name out
about five or six of these here
uh that have authorized us to use their
name from northern nevada if you're
watching online
oliver f of reno has won five thousand
dollars and german l of las vegas is a
five thousand dollar winner
and then here with us tonight you can
come on up when i call your name
ella s has won five thousand dollars
uh
valeria s
and kaylee j of las vegas
and luis j of north las vegas
thank you guys the six of you for our
five thousand dollar winners
now okay we'll bring you back up for
pictures is that what you
do
sure yeah yeah each one so if you want
to take a step back we're going to go
with the waist first
shelly you want to come over for yeah
take a step forward for me here
okay
we can tell you're smiling by your eyes
congratulations
[Music]
come on up
winner
now
moving on to our 20 000
college savings plan winners there are
three
this this week
and one of them is with us tonight
elijah h from las vegas
and brayden c of henderson come on up
[Applause]
i take a step forward
here we are
okay that leaves our fifty thousand
dollar college savings plan winner
uh in reno are they on the phone today
they're available i'm gonna call them
and i'll put on speaker
governor
oh it's going to come out as a no caller
id
or blocked id whatever
okay why am i having trouble getting it
okay here we go
the winner is
mihayla b
so
hello
hello mahila
hi hi this is steve sislek how are you
good
good well i hope you've just learned
that you have won the 50 000 college
savings plan
oh my god
i've got you on speakerphone and
everybody's listening to you so you are
our 50 000 winner
you still with me
thank you
you're very welcome we wish you all the
best
we wish you all the best and i hope that
you enjoy your account what where grade
are you in now
i'm in 10th grade 10th can you see your
sophomore huh you got a couple more
years to decide where you're going
yeah well this will give you a good
start on wherever you decide to go okay
okay thank you so much have a great
night okay bye-bye thank you
oh i didn't get to do that very often
that's kind of cool
now to our cash winners
to qualify for these cash drawings you
need to be in nevada
18 years of age or older who got their
covet 19 vaccine this week there are 10
1 000 cash winners
they are natasha a
michael c
sidney h
and marvin p all of las vegas
and then we have cassandra e
and cleopha w of north las vegas and
from searchlight nevada james s
you've all won a thousand dollars it's
great to see our rural communities got
in and got some vaccines and and are one
one of the prizes so congratulations
and for james some searchlight thanks
for going that extra mile to get the
vaccine
we have four
twenty five thousand dollar cash prizes
to announce tonight
and one fifty thousand dollar cash prize
winner to announce tonight
are three
one two three no i got i'm gonna
announce the four twenty thousand dollar
winners
from
diane l
from las vegas jose r
and here with us tonight a front line
health care worker from right here in
las vegas cyril c
is a twenty five thousand dollar cash
winner cyril
[Applause]
let's take a step this way
that leaves just one more winner tonight
tonight's fifty thousand dollar cash
winner is with us it probably figured
out that she is the fifty thousand
dollar winner
so we would like to call up jennifer r
who is fifty thousand dollars rich
jennifer y i'm sorry fifty thousand
dollars richer
[Music]
shout out to the cosmopolitan jennifer
works at the cosmopolitan and they have
gone above and beyond to administer
vaccines and we sincerely appreciate
what you're done and you are now 50 000
richer as a result of that so thank you
congratulations to all of the nevada vac
day winners
uh
we really appreciate
we have just two more weeks left to have
drawings and it's going to culminate in
two weeks with our one million dollar
prize winner being announced but
every person in nevada who gets a
vaccine is already a winner
you're already a winner because you got
the vaccine you're helping to save your
life and to save other people's lives
and along the way you might get lucky
like jennifer and win 50 000. there you
go we got a happy winner over here
and win some money but you're protecting
our community and we thank you for that
thank you all for being here with us
tonight it was really a lot of fun
shelley thank you so much for hosting us
in toro university thank you for
welcoming us in your doors and i thank
you again for the work that you're doing
on the pandemic front and please
continue to help us along the way we're
making a lot of progress and we couldn't
do it without you so thank you all for
joining us we look forward to seeing you
again next week thanks everybody
[Applause]